à l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois on est prêt à
accueillir de nouveaux lieux publics
dans les deux salles que compte le
cinéma cette réouverture est très
attendu après une année difficile alors
2020 ça a forcément été une année
compliquée où on a on a donc comme à peu
près toutes les salles de france perdu
50 à 55% de notre de notre fréquentation
après la réouverture prévue le 15
décembre le public pourra compter sur la
diffusion de films pour tous les publics
comme a dû décompte d'albert dupontel
ademe de maïwenn ou encore polly de
nicolas vanier et pour sa séance le
protocole sanitaire sera scrupuleusement
respectée il ya évidemment du gel
hydroalcoolique disponible partout le
masque est obligatoire dans les salles
pour toutes les personnes à partir de 11
ans ça c'est des choses qui sont
maintenus nous à l'espace noir est on a
mis en place également un sens de
circulation au ciné cette d'elancourt
mêmes mesures sanitaires
ici aussi on tient particulièrement à
mettre en avant le cinéma français
on va soutenir les films qui se sont
arrêtées de façon brutale notamment des
films français distribué par des
distributeurs français qu'on salue dans
toutes les salles de france parce que
heureusement qu'on a eu le cinéma
français et des distributeurs qui ont
comme snd comme venons grammy de dia
fanaf et c'est sur le courage de sortir
des films
qui ont d'ailleurs été récompensé parce
que ça a bien fonctionné pour les
cinéphiles il reste moins de deux
semaines à patienter pour retrouver les
salles obscures